[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis schönen guten abend zum
ende der woche das wichtigste vom sport
von norbert könig ja ein bisschen später
und die wichtigsten nachrichten jetzt im
überblick
makro oder lippen stichwahl um die
präsidentschaft in frankreich
angriffe auch am orthodoxen osterfest
die ukraine kündigt den besuch von us
ministern an
und rekordsieger thw kiel die
norddeutschen gewinn gegen magdeburg zum
zwölften mal den handball pokal
der liberale amtsinhaber immer nur im
makro oder die extrem rechte marine le
pen in frankreich entscheiden heute die
wahlberechtigten wer künftig im
elysée-palast sitzt und damit den kurs
des landes bestimmt nicht nur in
frankreich sondern in ganz europa schaut
man mit spannung auf den ausgang der
wahl in knapp einer stunde schließen die
letzten wahllokale am abend über das
finale rennen
er tritt an für eine zweite amtszeit
frankreichs präsident emanuel makro will
das land weiter reformieren setzt sich
für ein starkes europa ein in umfragen
lag er zuletzt vorn doch das land ist
gespalten so viel schon viel zu lange
sind die extrem rechten präsent in
frankreich und machen uns angst weil sie
abermals in die stichwahl gekommen sind
ich drücke die daumen für makro
penn als präsidentin würde frankreich in
den mittelpunkt stellen sie ist
nationalistisch und gegen ein europa wie
wir es heute erleben ich bin überhaupt
nicht mit ihr einverstanden
marine le pen gab am vormittag ihre
stimme in ihrem wahlkreis in
nordfrankreich ab einer der ärmsten
regionen des landes ihre sozialen
versprechen etwa die kaufkraft zu
stärken finden hier viel zuspruch
tut die tische alles wird immer teurer
mit marie le pen werden wir vielleicht
nicht reiche aber das leben wäre
gerechter
ich will einen wechsel in die richtige
richtung sie wäre die beste frankreich
steht vor einer richtungsentscheidung
eine entscheidung bei der auch für
europa viel auf dem spiel steht und für
uns stehende thomas weide und christel
hast dort wo makro und wo le pen hoffen
gleich einen wahlsieg feiern zu können
beginnen wir mal bei ihnen thomas in
einer stunde gibt die ersten
hochrechnungen wie siegessicher ist
meine macken lager
immer nur grau dann vor seine anhänger
treten wenn es verlässliche zahlen wenn
es ein resultat gibt bei den anhängern
und den mitarbeitern die schon hier sind
gibt es eine ganze bandbreite von
stimmung das haben wir festgestellt in
gesprächen das reicht von verhaltenem
optimismus wegen der letzten umfragen
die ganz gut aus sand für makro bis zu
großer nervosität weil die anhänger
makros und seine mitarbeiter zumindest
als katastrophe empfinden würden wenn le
pen gewinne weil dann ein gänzlich
anderes frankreich auf die weltbühne
treten würde nervös auch weil die zahlen
um 17 uhr der wahlbeteiligung etwas
niedriger waren als im ersten wahlgang
vor zwei wochen das meint man könnte
eine pen zu gute kommen aber diese
bandbreite die es ist große nervosität
die noch mit bis eine stunde anhalten
werden und christel wie zuversichtlich
sind die anhänger und anhängerin le pens
die 500 handverlesenen gäste die hier
zum wahlabend von marine le pen geladen
sind die tropfen so langsam ein und die
mit denen wir gesprochen haben die sind
sehr zuversichtlich sie glauben fest an
den sieg von marine le pen denn es ist
hier schließlich gelungen ihre partei
als eine feste größe in frankreich zu
verankern und sie hat ein sehr treues
und ein sehr stabiles eine sehr stabile
wählerschaft und sie kann wahrscheinlich
auch mit stimmen aus dem bürgerlichen
und auch aus dem ganz linken lager
rechnen also es wird ein sehr enges
rennen und es ist nicht auszuschließen
dass es heute abend noch eine
überraschung gibt dann kann sie beide
nach paris
und erste zahlen aus frankreich gibt es
in einem heute journal spezial ging zehn
nach acht
in die ukraine sollen heute nach angaben
kiers der us außen und der
us-verteidigungsminister kommen das wäre
der hochrangigste besuch aus den usa
seit kriegsbeginn
trotz bitten um eine waffenruhe zum
orthodoxen osterfest hat das russische
militär seine angriffe fortgesetzt wie
auf die hafenstadt odessa wie pablo sie
derlei berichtet
ein zerstörtes wohnhaus in odessa
vergangene nacht hat es erneut angriffe
auf die hafenstadt gegeben gestern waren
durch russischen raketen beschuss
mindestens acht menschen gestorben
darunter ein baby erklärte die ukraine
auch aus dem osten des landes werden
wieder angriffe gemeldet diese bilder
zeigen schweres artilleriefeuer offenbar
im don was in der stadt mariupol ist das
stahlwerk aus stahl weiter umkämpft die
vereinten nationen fordern eine
sofortige waffenruhe für die stadt
hoffnung liegt auf einem besuch von us
aussenminister blinken und
verteidigungsminister osten und kiew den
hatte der ukrainische präsident für
heute angekündigt kombiniert mit einer
klaren forderung
warum ist es so wichtig dass führende
politiker zu uns kommen pragmatisch
gesagt sie können nicht mit leeren
händen kommen wir erwarten keine
geschenke oder kuchen wir erwarten
bestimmte dinge und spezielle waffen
auch russland rüstet offenbar auf moskau
verstärkt nach ukrainischen angaben
seine truppen in grenznähe mit
kurzstreckenraketen vom typ iskander m
trotz des krieges begehen sie in der
ukraine heute feierlich den orthodoxen
ostersonntag so wie hier in der wladimir
kathedrale in kiew und auch in butter
feiern sie ostern dem ort der wie kaum
ein zweiter symbol für das grauen dieses
krieges geworden ist aus dem glauben
schöpfen sie hoffnung
cdu-chef märz hat die deutsche russland
politik scharf kritisiert auch die
seiner eigenen partei die gesamte außen
und sicherheitspolitik der letzten 20
jahre stehe vor einem scherbenhaufen
sagte er der bild am sonntag alle
verteidigungsminister ministerin hätten
falsche entscheidung getroffen von 2005
bis ende 2021 stunden politiker und
politikerinnen der union an der spitze
des verteidigungsministeriums mit
einem deutlichen votum hat sich der fdp
bundesparteitag für die lieferung auch
von schweren waffen an die ukraine
ausgesprochen generalsekretär bijan djir
sarai mahnte vor dem hintergrund des
krieges und der ukraine ein neues
kapitel in den transatlantischen
beziehungen an dazu gehöre auch ein
neuer anlauf für ein freihandelsabkommen
zwischen der eu und den usa
die linke stellt sich personell neu auf
auf dem parteitag ende juni wird der
gesamte vorstand vorzeitig neu gewählt
die partei ist in einer krise auch wegen
der jüngsten sexismus vorwürfe die ko
vorsitzende herr nicht so war mittwoch
zurückgetreten bis zum parteitag führt
janine wissler die linke nun allein
nach einer anti israelischen
demonstration in berlin hat
bundesinnenminister in phaser ein
konsequentes vorgehen gegen
antisemitismus angekündigt in unserer
gesellschaft gibt es keinen platz für
judenfeindlichkeit schrieb sie auf
twitter gestern waren hunderte
pro-palästinensische demonstrieren durch
die stadt gezogen sie skandierten israel
feindliche und antisemitische parolen
journalistinnen wurden angegriffen die
polizei ermittelt unter anderem wegen
volksverhetzung
und jetzt kommen wir zur formel 1 0 hat
sich ja heute weltmeister max verstappen
zurückgemeldet mit einem beeindruckenden
sieg im land der konkurrenten millionen
ferraris die schmalen den
titelverteidiger max verstappen hängt in
seinem vierten saison grand prix die
roten renner ab und verkürzte den
rückstand in der gesamtwertung auf
schall erklär erheblich sebastian vettel
wird achter es war ein hartes stück
arbeit für den viermaligen weltmeister
nicht immer nur auf der strecke
40 gut an es war trotzdem ein achter
platz aber für uns muss man ehrlich sein
ist das wie ein sieg schumacher
hoffnungsvoller center gestartet wird
nach diesem dreher vorletzter favorit
erklärt verliert schon am start zwei
plätze und riskiert in der schlussphase
an dritter stelle zu viel wird sechster
max dass daten und sergio perez feiern
gebührend und haben ferrari die party
zuhause gehörig verdorben
in der fußball bundesliga verliert
aufsteiger vfl bochum 0 zu 2 gegen
augsburg und verpasste es damit sich
vorzeitig den klassenerhalt zu sichern
und das dutzend ist voll der thw kiel
hat sich gegen den sc magdeburg in
hamburg zum zwölften mal den deutschen
handball pokal
um 15.22 begann die zwölfte pokalsieger
party des thw kiel in einem intensiven
spiel gelang dem sc magdeburg durch
magnus kolorit mit dem 17 zu 16 die
letzte führung danach kiel immer stärker
auch durch ihren überragenden torhüter
niklas landin der zweite garant sein der
seerosen der norweger markierte mit
seinem achten treffer den 28 zu 21
entstand die zebras tanzen der
pokalsieger 20 22 heißt thw kiel
und das war schon mit spott sagte
norbert und wir werfen noch einen kurzen
blick aufs wetter im norden wechseln
morgen sonne und wolken meist bleibt es
trocken sonst regnet es oft teils mit
gewittern die höchsttemperatur liegt
zwischen 10 grad an der ostsee und 17
grad im breisgau
am dienstag regnet es im süden dann wird
es freundlicher und wärmer christian
sievers hat um 21.45 das heute-journal
für sie schön sonntagabend